[Music]
oh they're not gonna see you they're not
gonna see you because you're Asian okay
there's the rude awakening
[Applause]
[Music]
was such a thrill to be able to play
that role and to it to be a person of
color in that room
[Music]
take us back then to Miss Saigon because
obviously you know some people some
people associate that it's being kind of
a big breakthrough rule and of course it
was it was yeah but you had been working
pretty extensively yeah I had been
working for about 10 years so how did
they find you because to be fair to be
fair they had been looking high and low
for the perfect launch for the perfect
and I mean if they started searching
first in London came up empty-handed
headed to America New York Los Angeles
Honolulu and ended up in Manila I mean
it truly catapulted you into I hate
using the phrase but a whole new world
for you talk about that now let we'll
talk about that a little bit later but
just tell us what it was like being
young you're very young when I
auditioned and 18 when we started
rehearsals 17 years old out of the
Philippines yeah and you've got this
kind of dashing Oh cheeky as anything
but it was must have been quite
difficult it was difficult um because I
had not had a romantic relationship at
that point in my life so I knew nothing
literally zero and I think this was a
source of frustration for Cameron
Mackintosh and Nicholas Hytner who was
directing and finally Nicholas had to
demonstrate exactly what he needed me to
do and there was one point where he had
to demonstrate these things what Simon
Bowman which is you'd think it'd be
uncomfortable but it was actually
incredibly helpful but Simon was so
sweet about everything and when that the
point came when I realized oh my god
this is what I'm gonna have to do and he
he could see that I was terrified and
that my mum was terrified as well
he sat my mum down first and spoke to
her and then he sat the both of us down
together and basically said the things
that every leading lady that young in a
show this big should hear from her
leading man you can trust me I will not
take advantage of you I will take care
of you yeah nice really she's been
talking about it now I get
emotional your own in Michigan was
incredibly well-received you're winning
awards left right and center complain
yeah I presume at that point then the
other job offers just came rolling in no
not so much
hmm why was that um one would think I
mean there is this automatic thing that
you assume that if you're when you win
the Tony Award that the jobs will just
keep you got one in this side of the
Olivier on this side of the pond and
then more Awards on the other side but
yeah things were coming in and there was
actually an audition for a show that my
agent submitted me for my agent at the
time and he's like I've submitted you to
audition for this and and I said alright
sure I but the minute he said the show
I'm like I'm really not the right vocal
part and ten minutes later he calls me
back and he says oh they're not gonna
see you they they're not gonna see you
because you're Asian I'm like okay
there's the rude awakening that was kind
of jus to arrive but not long after that
I get a call from Cameron's office from
one of his associate producers and
called me into a meeting and in his
office and said I want to cast you as
éponine in Lane Mizzou Rob and so when
the opportunity came it was like I knew
that score like the back by then I knew
that score like the back of my hand
backwards and forwards name it name any
role I could sing it it was I was that
obsessed with it I guess in the same way
that a lot of young people are now
obsessed with Hamilton or a generation
ago with wicked it's that same kind of
power that that musical held for me and
it was such a thrill to be able to play
that role and to you know to be a person
of color in that role the first Asian
actress to do it yeah
[Music]
I did but as it but as a professional I
mean to be identified not as just a
fantastic portrayal of the role but as
the first Asian to go with that there
there is some expectation and I think I
spent quite a few sleepless nights
thinking I'm sure that there are people
out there who are just waiting for me to
mess up just so that they can say see
look it doesn't work so I I really made
sure that I nailed that song hmm like on
opening night and on every night
afterwards I was just that driven to
make sure that to give no-one any room
to say anything negative about that how
do you feel though because it does seem
sometimes this is not from someone with
a huge musical theater background it did
play you know The Artful Dodger in Kyle
Academy's production of all of her one I
was fantastic but at the same time
historically there have been an awful
lot of Caucasian actors and actresses
yeah have played Asian rooms but not the
other way around
nope and certainly we were not always
given the opportunity to play the roles
that we are absolutely right for there's
there a part of you that that in any way
resents the efforts that you had to go
to no no I would have be resentful
I mean I'm enjoying the fruits of all of
that now with a really wonderful career
that sees no signs of stopping anytime
soon I mean still so many firsts that
I'm experiencing in my life and I get to
do what it is I love to do the most
I can't resent all of that if it led me
to all of this you know and if it meant
making things easier for succeeding
generations of Asian actors to get roles
then you know what it was all worth it
well it certainly hurts yeah I mentioned
um obviously I have to mention being a
Disney Princess in terms of career
highlights that's not bad it's got to be
up there some it definitely is I was not
feeling cute that particular day no
makeup hair up in a topknot and a really
ugly wind
sweater because it was cold and it
worked out because they said we don't
need to see you we only need to hear you
sing so we're going to bow our heads and
and just really listen to you so please
don't be offended to this day people
must do Joe I mean just that that to see
you sing this I mean that must bring
that's the one that brings the house
down isn't it I'm sure they all do
obviously right yeah that's got to be up
there it is up there and I always call
somebody from the audience to do it with
me
like I asked for a volunteer to to come
up and and and a lot of the times most
of the time I will get someone who is
incredible hmm who could be doing this
for a career and then sometimes I'll get
the odd lemon here and there who should
not be anywhere near a microphone so
yeah we have a day I'm I'm not turning
up to the gig no thanks you tell us been
a bit Milan and the experience with that
as well cuz you know doing one in
Destiny's film you know everyone's done
yeah it's a rare thing if there are very
few actors that have done more than one
so I feel like I'm in a very exclusive
small mem you know Club I'm very very
lucky but yeah Milan was that one I
actually also had to audition for
because just because you you've done one
successfully it doesn't mean it doesn't
automatically mean that you're right
for another one you know an Oscar an
Oscar in the cupboards you know that
doesn't stand for anything yeah yeah
it's fine
yeah that song that song it's not you
don't your favor of the two is it
infectious I know I think it has because
it's become kind of it's become sort of
its own thing now because a whole new
world is kind of like the big family
sing-along I think the concert but
moulana there it kind of means its its
meaning has just continued to evolve
and it's a song about representation
about it being important to see somebody
that reflects you when you're sitting in
an audience you look up onstage and you
see somebody that actually looks like
you that's important do you think that
happens enough these days in theory
could happen more if you had one piece
of advice for for people who like
yourself yeah want to increase the
amount of diversity on the stages of the
world what would it be like do it
because it's the right thing to do
because I think there I think there are
people who are afraid that it's not
going to generate revenue and I mean
producers as business people kind of
have that it at the forefront of their
minds but if anything like films such as
crazy rich Asians has proven and black
panther and and so many other shows I
mean I mean come on Hamilton just by
itself if there's anything that these
shows are proving it's that when you put
people of color in shows and on film it
means that there will be more people who
will yeah you're all of a sudden you're
catering to another segment of the
population with disposable income to put
into those movies just in terms of to
where you are in your career known as
you Keisei as you said right at the very
beginning you know you're keeping
heading first whenever you find the
opportunities of have have expanded as
you've gotten older I think I'm getting
more interesting roles to play now yeah
because I've kind of graduated from the
aunjanue Club because I'm 48 years old
which means that the offers I'm starting
to get are for things that are a little
more interesting you're arriving at that
age and the roles that are going to
start arriving are roles that are really
meaty and
interesting because it's not about
looking pretty anymore and that's
exciting and that's exciting
to think about so who knows what's gonna
what kind of first is going to end up on
my lap